[Music]
all right so for this week's guitar
lesson we have a very basic chord
progression
three chords an e a and a b
chord and when i strum it like this it's
so incredibly boring and i know a lot of
you are in this situation where you
know how to play all your basic chords
but you want to make them sound more
interesting
and so that's what this week's lesson is
all about how do you take those same
basic chords like that and just
embellish on them so by the end of this
it'll sound like this
[Music]
so
hey this is brian with activemelody.com
well as i mentioned we're going to be
learning about
embellishments and how we take some
basic chords and we just embellish them
and make them sound much better than
they are so in this video we're going to
be looking at
what to play over an e an a and a b
chord but you don't want to be limited
to just one key you want to be able to
play this in any key and so for premium
members i have an extra
video that explains how to transpose
this and play this in another in the key
of g
which you can then take that and play in
any key because there's no open strings
so i've got that extra video for premium
members if you want to watch that i've
also got the tablature for both keys as
well as the on-screen tab viewer
which is interactive so you can get all
of those things if you want by going to
activemelody.com go to the weekly
lessons page
and do a search for ep267
all right so i find myself playing more
of these embellishment
licks off of chord shapes than probably
anything else
because most of time if especially if
you're jamming with other people
uh you know you're not always playing a
solo and when you're playing rhythm
most people if you have a group of
guitar players most people are just
going to be strumming the chords they're
going to be looking at a chord chart or
something
you don't want to be one of those people
you want to be somebody that can go a
little bit
beyond that and play some more
interesting things also for those of you
that are
solo performers you know you sing play
guitar
and you're looking for feel likes you
know things you can do in between the
verses or in between the phrasing in
between the chords what can you do to
just sort of make it sound a little
better
these are great for that and so uh so
they're
great in between vocal phrases if you're
playing with another vocalist all that
kind of stuff
so you can keep all that in mind as we
go into it now the first thing that i'm
going to play
is really looking at i'm thinking about
two uh
chor it's the same chord it's an e chord
but i'm picturing this chord shape which
is the one you
you know the e chord down here but i'm
also picturing
an e chord up here using the d chord
shape out of the caged system c-a-g-e-d
i have a lesson on that ep 273 if you
want to go back and refer
to the cage system and how it all works
but um
this is an e chord when you play a d
chord up here now just play the top
three strings
but what i like to do is
when i'm playing in the key of e now
this doesn't work in all keys this just
works in the key of e
i'll show you how to do it in all keys
but in this case we're gonna play
strings uh one and three on the fourth
fret
but we're going to leave the open second
string that open b note
so the b note would be in the e chord so
um anyway we can take this shape now
and slide it down two frets
now you know where this shape comes from
it comes from that e chord shape up here
slide it down two frets and then down to
the e so what i've just done
in my mind is i don't just have an e
chord like this when i'm strumming
i've got this i've got this and i've got
this
and i've also got this and i've got
sauce
chords and all that but we're gonna get
into that later but
uh anyway that's what this is is a way
to think about the e chord
[Music]
with with these embellishments like that
the other way you've heard this chord is
with blues
when you walk it down chromatically so
you can do a lot of stuff with it
okay so when i started this i slid in
on the third string there we started on
the second fret actually slid up to the
fourth
and then i hit that low sixth string
though open e
[Music]
come down to the e chord and then we go
to the four chord which is the a
and then back to the one chord now this
right here
let me show you how to play it then i'll
i'll explain the theory behind this to
help you be able to use this in anything
so we're just going to bar the first
four strings on the second fret
and then we're going to go i'm going to
doing a slide there from the second fret
fifth string
up to the fourth fret with your ring
finger make sure you use your ring
finger for that
so that you can come up here in bar with
your index finger
and then we're going to play strings
four and three out of that second fret
back to the fourth fret fifth string and
then watch this
that's a hammer on between the second
fret and the fourth fret on the fourth
string
but you're also playing the third string
behind the bar there so you have
[Music]
and then back to that second fret and
then we're going to conclude that liquid
so this is where we bar
the first five strings now on the second
fret we're going to play strings five
and four
and we're going to do a hammer on to the
fourth fret fifth string
and then a slide from the second fret to
the fourth fret on the sixth string
and then we're going to come up and play
the second fret fourth string
down to the e the low e the sixth string
now that seems like a lot let me back up
and play that
[Music]
now obviously as a premium member you
have access to the tab so you can get
you know in under the hood and super
scientific with it that way if you want
but let me explain what's going on here
this is this will be a big light bulb
moment for a lot of you
in terms of embellishments off basic
chord shapes so the a
chord shape that we're playing off which
is the a chord
you have this box here between the
fourth fret
and the second fret on string three four
and five what i mean by that is anytime
you're playing an a
chord
you've got all these little things you
can do between that fourth fret and
second fret anytime any of those notes
are going to work
so try that just play play an a chord
and see what you can start to do with it
what's really cool is you can take that
and play it in
any key so you don't have to just do
that with an a if we wanted to play
a c chord using the a chord shape so we
take that chord shape and slide it up
what i'm gonna have to do is i'm gonna
have to replace where my pinky is in
this case with my index finger
but i've still got that same box this
case it would be between the seventh
fret
and the fifth fret string four five i'm
sorry three
four and five so now
[Music]
i've got these embellishments off that c
chord
but it's using the same concept that we
just learned there so
anyway that that's one of the light
bulbs the other light bulb
is what you have off of the e chord
shape so that's the a shape that we just
learned now the e
shape you've got the same frets fret
four
and two but but it's going to be string
strings four
five and six same thing but we just slid
everything down a set of strings
so now if i'm playing an e chord i've
[Music]
got
right all of these licks can make them
country you can make them blues rock
whatever you want
but they're off of that chord shape and
i like to connect things to chord shapes
because if i wanted to do this in the
key of g
i just look for my e chord there it is
right there so that little box
[Music]
right it's right there
so now you've got these two um
zones that you can play within off of
the a chord shape
and the e chord shape and so all of that
was to
explain why
[Music]
why that works so you can see you're
going
[Music]
that's off the a and then that's
back to the e let's take it from the
beginning and play up to that point
[Music]
okay now after that we're going to come
up here and play an e chord we're back
to the e chord now
but instead of me playing it down here i
wanted to play in a different position
to show you some different options so
we're going to hit that open sixth
string
and then we're going to play our e chord
here now this is using the c chord
shape out of caged if i played a c chord
like this which is not how we would
normally
the fingers we would use that is how you
play it and i slid that all the way up
to here
but then barred where the nut was to as
a capo
i've got an e chord now most of the time
i'm not using my pinky when i do this
but in this case i wanted to include it
just to show you how to play the chord
properly
so then the embellishment is with your
pinky
so you can come up here and take your
pinky off go to the sixth fret third
string
but you're playing strings three and two
[Music]
and then we're going to do a bend a half
bend
on the sixth fret fourth string
and then come down to the fourth fret
fourth string
[Music]
and then we're gonna play
the the b chord but using the a chord
shape
so we're repurposing a lot of what we're
doing so when i played
played that this should make sense now
because look at what it is it's a box
now between the sixth fret and the
fourth fret
there's your chord there's your b chord
you should be able to see it now
that same thing that we did over the a
i'm i'm taking a a few notes out of this
but it's out of the same place the same
little position there
and hopefully that makes sense as to why
that works off the b chord
[Music]
so we play the b like that
and then i went and this
is just walking from this b chord i'm
still playing the b chord but i'm
using this finger finger and the bass or
this note in the bass so that would be
the sixth fret
uh fifth string you can see i'm barring
there on the fourth
fret first four strings i've got that
ring finger on the sixth fret
uh fifth string and that's again
it's just one of those notes in the
little box there so you've got two ways
you can play that chord
you can play it like this like kind of
like the a chord shape or you can play
it
up in this position which is getting
into the
the g chord shape out of cage if we want
to get super technical but
anyway i don't want it to grass too far
so um
i walked it up just like a bass player
would do and i used just one finger for
that
to go from the fourth fret to the sixth
fret
and then another little embellishment
with my pinky
on the sixth fret fourth string but i'm
playing strings four and three
so let's back it up from the beginning
and play to that point
[Music]
there's your e here's your a
back to the e
[Music]
[Applause]
there's your b
[Music]
okay now we're gonna go back to the e so
i just hit the open six string because i
wanted to come up here
and play a harmonized third and show you
this now what i'm doing is i've got my
ring finger on the ninth fret second
string
index finger is on the seventh fret
first string
and i'm playing out of this e chord
shape now so i'm picturing
e chord e chord e chord
this would be the top part of that e
chord up here this is using the a
shape but i'm playing strings one and
two out of that shape
and that's where that comes from it's a
harmonized third
[Music]
slide that down two frets and then we're
going to go into this position which
would be
middle finger on the fifth fret second
string index finger on the fourth fret
first
this is just a major scale
which i covered in lesson a few weeks
ago on uh harmonized thirds you can look
that one up i can't remember the number
but anyway we go hit the open sixth
string
[Music]
it's a nice embellishment it sounds
great in lieu of playing a full chord
right
[Music]
and then we go to the four chord which
is the a and i play
and what what that is is that's an
a sus4 suspended uh four chord
let me show you how to play it so you
bar the first three strings on the fifth
fret
and then you take your middle finger i'm
sorry your ring finger and your pinky
on the seventh fret strings uh what is
that three
and four on the seventh fret and then
you throw in that open fifth string
so it sounds like that and that's an a
sus4 chord let me just explain sus
chords because this is another thing
that will really help with your uh chord
playing and
enhancements around chords uh a sus
four chord you have two suspended chords
um you have a four and a two
and all it is is the major scale so if
we were playing an
a and looking at the a major scale
you have one and you know your chord is
made up of the
root third and fifth the one three and
five so instead of the
uh the third we're gonna make it the
fourth so you have one
two three four so one four
and then five that would be a sus4 chord
that's where the four comes from
the same with the the two it's just the
second one two
and then you do the five so that would
be an a
sus2 and you've heard that it's an
unresolved core that's why it's called a
suspended chord
because it's not resolving to anything
it's um
so uh the reason i'm mentioning that is
now when you're playing a chords and
you're strumming chords
look at what you can do with these
suspended chords like if i'm playing an
a chord
i can take a finger off and get the sus2
i can add a finger in this case would be
third fret second string
to get the sus4 but you hear that in a
lot of music
sounds a little better than just
strumming the a chord so the thing to
remember with sus two and four chords is
uh you're going to want to make sure you
know them off of your a
shape off of your e
shape right
[Music]
and then off of your d shape
so if you know it off those three chord
shapes you can do
just about anything because now i can
play an a sus4 or two in all these
different positions
and you can do all these variations off
of them so once i come to that a sus4
i play a triplet one two three string
one two three and then i go ahead and
play the a
chord i put my middle finger there on
the sixth fret third string
to resolve it see how it unresolved
resolved
so then we go back to the one chord and
the way i did it there was a keith
richards move or i always think of this
as the keith richards thing
play the open sixth string and then i'm
just barring there on the fourth fret
playing strings four three and two a
little triad there
i do a hammer on with my middle finger
the fifth fret second string ring finger
six fret uh fourth string
and all that is is your c chord shape
we're just not using the pinky there
okay
and then we go to the five chord which
is the b
and i'm just playing a b7 chord actually
down here with my pinky on the second
fret first string
so that i can go
back to the e now that's another little
takeaway nice takeaway to remember
when you're playing the five chord down
here or playing this b7 chord
you've got this little half band that
you can do
and to get back to the one chord it
sounds really good it's easy to remember
so that's pinky on the second fret first
string
a bend and release open one
second fret second string back to the
one string
and then to resolve it we have
now that should sound familiar because
that's the e sus
4 chord resolving back to the e chord
and to do that
i'm just hammering on with my pinky to
the second fret third string
open thirds or actually the third just
the third string behind the e chord here
i've got my
index finger in the first fret do the
hammer on
open second string open one
take your pinky off to resolve on to the
e chord
and so all of that is just a series of
little
embellishments and and ideas you know to
help you
play some more interesting things when
you're playing an e chord now don't just
think of
this you've got other positions and
other licks and things
and so it's just a matter of over time
once you understand
just these basics you can start really
adding to these make sure you get your
sus2 and your sus4
off the e shape the a shape and the d
shape
and and the rest of it i guess i
explained
so let me back up i'll play through it
one more time slowly and remember as a
premium member you have access
to the second video where i explain how
to transpose this and play it in other
keys
and you also have access to the
tablature for for both
um so i'm going to back up play through
it one more time and then
we'll see you in the next video all
right so we have
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
you